it is clear from this report that I have
not committed any contempt of parliament
it is also clear that what I have been
saying about this matter from the
beginning has been Vindicated that is
because there is no evidence in the
report that I knowingly or recklessly
misled Parliament or that I failed to
update parliament in a timely manner nor
is there he goes on to say any evidence
in the report that I was aware that any
events taking place in number 10 or the
cabinet office were in breach of the
rules or the guidance like any prime
minister I relied upon advice from
officials there is no evidence he says
that I was at any stage advised by
anyone whether a civil servant or a
political advisor that an event would be
against the rules or the guidance before
it went ahead interestingly the
statement is quite lengthy I'm just
going to jump ahead to the sex question
in which he says I note that the
committee has emphasized their wish to
be fair they have made reference on no
fewer than 26 occasions to a personage
they bashfully describe as the second
permanent secretary to the cabinet
office that is of course he says Sue
gray so it is surreal to discover that
the committee proposes to rely on
evidence cold and orchestrated by Sue
gray who has just been appointed Chief
of Staff to the leader of the labor
party
uh let's get uh let's bring in our
political correspondent Tamara Cohen who
is at uh number 10 for us this afternoon
a very Punchy statement there from
former prime minister Boris Johnson most
unusual isn't it for him to be saying
that the report basically vindicates
everything that he said ahead of him
giving evidence to the committee on the
20th of March well this is all a quite
extraordinary really Sam and the role of
Sue gray is very interesting you'll
remember of course that after Sue gray
carried out her report into partygate as
the top official in charge of propriety
and ethics now she was not the person
who was initially asked to carried out
the person who was initially asked
carried out was the cabinet secretary
the most senior civil servant Simon case
but he had to understand aside because
of allegations that one of the
Gatherings he had attended so she was
asked to step in it wasn't her choice to
lead that inquiry and in fact when that
inquiry report came out last year you
will remember that Boris Johnson said he
believed he had been Vindicated by it
and it blamed a culture a general
culture in Downing Street for some of
these failures of course she's not the
only person to look into it as the prime
minister's official spokesman has just
been saying uh two political journalists
in a meeting in a Lobby briefing just
now other bodies including of course the
police also looked into it which is why
Boris Johnson and indeed the current
prime minister Rishi senac had a fine
but so it's interesting that the Downing
Street having stayed out of this we've
now got Boris Johnson saying that he is
concerned he said it's surreal to
discover that they are relying on
evidence provided by the Sue gray report
now many of those have been particularly
angry about partygate felt that um they
were they were disappointed that Sue
Gray's report was not able to go further
um into some of those Gatherings and
indeed um the committee of MPS who's now
looking at whether Boris Johnson misled
Parliament on that specific issue the
committee that's produced this report
the expectation was that they would be
able to publish more pictures and more
testimony that we hadn't previously seen
about what went on at these gatherings
at first glance it looks as if at least
one of those pictures is new the picture
of Boris Johnson surrounded on a table
with some with some champagne bottles
that wasn't something that we saw in the
sougre report the pictures there showed
gather at small gatherings in the
cabinet room which looked quite a bit
like like work meetings although Boris
Johnson did get a fine over one of those
Gatherings so the fact that Boris
Johnson has chosen to hit out at Sue
gray whose Sky News being revealed is
now planning to take a job as Chief of
Staff to the labor leader certainly
sharpens this meeting the mood ahead of
this meeting that he's going to have
with those MPS next week and it looks as
if he's going to come out fighting he's
of course taken legal advice on ahead of
this and he seems very confident from
that statement that he is in the clear
as to whether he misled Parliament I
think we expected that one of the more
damaging aspects of this inquiry would
be the pictures and the testimony that
comes out and we have not seen all of it
today though maybe more to come when the
inquiry does its full report after it's
spoken to Boris Johnson that that is
shaping up to be quite a fiery session
next week